[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing it's a nice day
and it's a nice day to comment on
something which is very viral on the
internet
the neural link and obviously our
brother zeeshan from smile to janna has
an entire video on this which you can
check out
but let me talk about this because
actually when i went to santa clara i
went to santa clara which is also known
as
silicon valley and i had a debate
with one of the intellectuals there or
one of the
people who represented atheism an
atheism debate in
sacramento and i was in california and i
went to santa clara
and there was someone who actually works
with elon musk
who came to me and he said he wants to
have me speak to elon musk
privately and so on and so forth and at
that time
the schedules were conflicting i mean i
had to go back to london
i had to go to la first and then go back
to london and so the schedules were
conflicting and unfortunately i wasn't
able
to make that that meeting but of course
now if we
uh want to reschedule it we can i know
obviously elon musk
or his employees or anyone who works for
him can
contact me uh on the email that belongs
to this channel you can obviously go to
the about us
page or the section on the youtube
channel and send me an email
with the appropriate titling but having
said this now
the reason why i've just thought of elon
musk is because of the whole neural link
discussion that's being had but before
we have that discussion and
before i comment on those things let's
see what elon musk actually said which i
thought
was quite problematic let's take a look
at what he says will you be able to save
and replay
memories in the future
uh yes i think uh in the future you will
be able to save and
replay memories um i mean this is
obviously sounding increasingly like a
black mirror episode
before i comment on this situation here
with elon musk
i want to say something which is that
you know back in the days
magic used to be illusionary you used to
have some kind of you know trick
to take the bunny out of the hat and so
on that would be magic
but i want to give you maybe a thought
experiment something to think about
if we brought one of our smartphones or
maybe a rocket or
a car and we transported it back to
let's say the 8th century or the 9th
century what do you think people would
say about this instrument this
technological instrument i'm pretty sure
that they would call this magical and
the reason why
they would call this magical is because
for them it's completely inexplicable
they can't explain it in any way shape
or form
so they would attribute it to the demons
they would attribute it
to magic and magic really works best
when the person who's doing it is able
to delude
in a sense deceive individuals into
thinking
that they can do something which is not
actually possible
which defies the scope of the empirical
reality
and i think that to be honest with you
um when i was growing up i used to watch
these
you know when i was a kid i used to
watch people like david blaine and these
you know
famous magicians recently i saw david
blaine he's on the
gre uh joe rogan experience podcast
and he was vomiting out some frogs and i
i promise you even joe rogan was
felt sick and disgusted from this and i
don't think
that we have room for that kind of
illusionary type of magic anymore it's
boring now it's
the thing of the past it's a waste of
time
and actually it's quite disgusting in
the case of the example i just gave you
but the most effective magic i see
happening now
relates to people speaking in
technological terms scientific terms
so-called
scientific so-called technological terms
in ways which makes people think that
they can do things
which they can't actually do and of
course
from an islamic perspective and i know
from a christian perspective as well
the meta narrative is at the end of
times there will be an antichrist
and this antichrist or from the islamic
perspective
will literally deceive people into
thinking that they he can
raise people back from the dead
and of course this is impossible
it could be the case god knows best
that the antichrist does so using
technological jargon
because now almost if you use technology
like elon musk has in the clip that
we've seen
you can pretty much try and justify
anything so let's get to the point of
why what elon musk said itself is really
problematic
and it bypasses so many discussions are
happening in academia
in such a you know casual way let's talk
about it
so when he was asked about saving and
retrieving
memories elon musk states
that he thinks it's possible to do so
but what our memories really are
composite of
what our memories really are composite
of because memories
are not just the information retrieved
from the five
senses they are not just the information
retrieved from the five senses
memories are also the experiences or the
first person subjective
states otherwise known sometimes as
emotions that we had
when we were undergoing such things
whatever it is that we were going
through
so i want you to think of a memory that
you you're acquainted with
maybe with a loved one now obviously if
i were watching the same thing if
for example you got that video of
you and your son daughter mother
uh father person that you love and it
was a really meaningful memory to you
and i watched it on a television set am
i gonna have the same experience with
that
information as you would of course not
of course not the reason why is because
the feelings that you had
interacting with that information are
completely different to the feelings
that i have
now the question is can emotions be
saved
stored and retrieved the answer is
unequivocally no
they can't be because they're
first-person subjective experiences
and as thomas sneagle says science is
the work of third person
science works in the third person so how
can third-person science access in the
first place
first person subjective experiences
another issue is this say for example we
take the physicalist view
which by the way is unprovable through
neurology
because physicalism is an assumption
it's a metaphysical
philosophical assumption and you have to
have this assumption in order to think
somehow that it's possible to take
first-person subjective experiences and
save them and retrieve them
but let's say for the sake of argument
we take this view
to be charitable and say
we put an individual under an mri scan
and we
activate for example we stimulate
their love center for example by showing
them pictures or videos
of people that they love showing them on
the other hand pictures and videos of
people that they hate
and tracking in the on their brain
the centers the neurological centers
which
activate when you know the when they are
reminded of the people that they love
versus when they're like
reminded of the people that they hate
you'll see in the brain
in that mapping for the sake of argument
a certain area
or certain neurons reacting in a certain
way let's say for the sake of argument
they react in ways
call it abc love whenever love is
present
abc is present in the brain this is a
neurological
uh kind of like you know a reaction to
love
abc and whenever hate is with the the
the opposite whenever hate is there cde
neurological pathways are activated and
firings happen
in on the mind on the brain sorry and
when this happens
okay you think
as the scientists so love equals abc and
hey equals
cde right are you with me here so
you got the brain under the mri and
you're stimulating it with love and hate
and you think love is abc and you think
hate is d
c d e okay now
in the case of love which is abc in the
case of love which is abc
the question is is neurological pathway
abc
only present when love is present
so david papanua says no
and this is the argument an undercutter
for me
in the academic literature which i
believe smackdown
is a smackdown argument for this kind of
reasoning if
only love caused abc then you'd have
more of an argument but it's not the
case that abc
is instantiated only when love is there
and even if that was the case whenever
love is there and only love
abc is there then there'd be an issue
with
saying that correlation equals causation
so there's two layers of problem
which show us how it is impossible even
on physicalist grounds
that emotions can sometimes somehow be
saved and retrieved and then
saved and then retrieved so
this is where individuals
who who use technology
may not be who may not be acquainted
with the academic literature on the
topic
on the heart problems of consciousness
will make such claims very casually
to make people think that they can
actually do things which are not
possible
in fact it's not possible to save let me
tell you this now it's not possible to
save
and retrieve how you felt about anything
because how you felt is a first person
subjective state
and how you felt is inextricably linked
to how
and what you did and that is
the equation for an experience and a
memory otherwise
it's the same as me videoing something
on my phone saving and retrieving what's
the difference a neural link you put it
in your brain
video and something on my phone there's
not much difference you see
so here it's very important to note that
those postulations that are made
are false because if we start to believe
these individuals who speak in these
technological ways
and these scientific ways in order to
really make philosophical arguments
or at least make assumptions which have
uh
make arguments which have philosophical
presuppositions physicalist
presuppositions in this case
then that is the slippery slope
that will lead ultimately to
believing that these individuals are
worth
your in in a sense mental subordination
quite frankly
mental and ideologically even
subordination
and this is the pathway leading to the
antichrist from our perspective leading
to
the gel from our perspective so we have
to be careful of
those realities so the reason why this
is
important to this whole narrative of the
antichrist
is because from our perspective as
muslims that the jail the antichrist
will come at the end of times and will
tell people
that look i'm going to be able to raise
your parents i'm going to be able to
raise the dead i'm going to be able to
do these things and
and then finally he's gonna ask people
for his worship
which is really in truly submission
mental
and ideological submission so i say to
elon musk it'll be really interesting
uh you know it was two years ago when i
was meant to come and see you
in silicon valley with the invitation of
your
your colleague or your employee
in santa clara and of course i'm willing
to do that
still like we can have a conversation on
zoom we and so on and so forth but the
point is
these are big questions about life and
the quran actually has something to say
about life in general and about what you
can and can't do
and by knowing what you can't do then
you can't aspire to impossibility
and the quran says this look
at me
those who you call besides god and take
as gods in other words you worship and
you give them that mental subordination
and that
you know that absolute subordination
submission
besides the creator god allah we call
allah
they will not even be able to create a
fly
because even if you get the chemical
things that are required for a fly to be
you will never be able to
to put in that fly first person
subjective experiences
you will never be able to give that fly
consciousness life-bearing consciousness
and therefore you'll never be able to
create a fly in the first place
the quran says even if they come
together and try
and do so so knowing all those things
will let us know
what the limits are to science and
technology generally
and not allow us to give ourselves as
slaves
to such individuals who speak in
scientific
and technological jargon but intend
nothing but
magic was like
you